j'avais juste des petites comme nous
juste comme nous mais l'autre jour j'ai
parlé des grèves et tu m'as dit fait de
se remettre casser la gueule dans la rue
une fois sur le gilet jaune
je vais donner mon avis sur les ventes
les jugeant victimes moi j'étais plutôt
contre un moment mais on exige est sorti
par l'arrière de 10,6 à faire de france
mais ce qui m'attendait devant et on m'a
dit sur des réseaux sociaux à terme ta
gueule tu es un riche mais tout est doux
je suis né avec de l'oseille on a donné
chair dans une banque comme à donner de
l'argent etc et quand j'entends des gens
comme toi qui dis c'est pas un métier ce
père mâtinée de star applaudir déjà
battue bleue
on essaie par les way home laissez pas
et s'il vous plaît vraiment tu peux pas
dire il ya plein de gens et a mis
l'allemagne en émoi infirmières ya plein
de gens qui rêvent il rêvait d'être mais
elles sont vides et d'afrique elles ont
choisi s'est affirmé appuyer le jour il
ya la fédé la galère des infirmières je
suis libre je puisse qui marque une
attraction du tri normale
d'institutrices il ya plein de gens moi
pas toi ma fille va être institutrice et
l attrait de ce métier bah non non non
non pas du tout médecin alors évidemment
pompiers c'est un vrai beau mi-saison
les policiers c'est un rêve d'être
profité pour s'y voir ça au clavier ça
que je parle au nom mais je verrai des
prêts s'est soulagé l éco boulanger les
chéris ya peu de gens qui rêvent d
maintenant songer à les coller aux ja
boucher y avoir des débouchés faire la
passe ou ça fait six ans mais c'est
quand même assez combien animateur de
télé pour
louper non inimitiés ya des maladresses
crise en syrie les dépressions mais je
me servais s'était pas constituée
la passion du boulot c'est des artisans
et les six hectares entre maisons des
chenaux travail a été je suis pas contre
l'agrémentent allure a dit non ça tu
décridibilise aussi tous les gens qui
sont ici et qui bossent et ben on étudie
les électro c'est pas un vrai métier les
électrodes des cinémas qui dénaturent je
sais pas parler des maquilleurs on les
applaudit les maquignons non on ne vais
jamais cessé le travail pour ne pas
léser méritoire et journée désordres
mentaux réussir hier que cheryl les paye
tous les jours et oui madame
hebbadj avait des encadreurs les électro
les mcr mais il travaille parce qu'aussi
il ya une émission est parce qu si on
écoute on est bien sur mes autres latham
et cyril organiser ce grand barnum de la
télévision ça cette émission et puis
c'est pas bien fou rire la journée pour
préparer l'émission il faut juger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas dans là il n'est pas
maquillée pas dans les lumières c'est un
animateur au micro de plein air avec son
micro parce que tout le monde a droit de
s'exprimer si jamais raymond tu en train
de dire par ailleurs je vais prendre
quelqu'un qui fait l'émission voit que
je regarde tous les jours que j'aime
avancé demandé mon émission préférée à
la télé c'est que la télé va vous tuer
entre à dire que valéry mézague n'a pas
vrai travail pas dit non mais là où je
te reproche quelque chose là c'est de
monter les uns contre les autres
je suis désolé non par ben moi il n'y a
pas de hiérarchie dans les métiers notre
tout le monde tout le monde travaille
alors il décrit des métiers qui sont
plus pénibles de l'autre l'ucl des
métiers qu'on a envie de plus de faire
que d'autres des métiers qui sont des
métiers passion et des métiers qui sont
des métiers raisons peu un peu d'accord
ça j'ai longtemps mais de dire que par
exemple nous on serait des sortes de
fainéants qui ne méritant pas d'avoir
une retraite qui ne méritons pas ceci ou
cela c'est pas bien de faire ça parce
que tout le monde travaille
après effectivement il ya des gens qui
travaillent avec qui ont beaucoup plus
de chaleur calme et olivia dunham et
éventuellement d'amérique latine ont
maintenant que tu répondes recherches je
vous dis ça réagit de ouf sur les
réseaux là dessus
vraiment je vous le dis c'est la folie
c'est pour ça que je continue avec peu
le débat parce que là vraiment les gens
sont comme des fous sur la réaction
excuses pour avoir des réactions en
direct s'il vous plaît sur twitter parce
que j'ai un âge y énormément régis
calmement à valérie que tu sais très
bien que je t'adore c'est très bien mais
tu l'as dit tu as tout dit il ya des
métiers passion il ya des métiers raison
quand tu décides de faire de ta carrière
un métier passion pendant 50 60 70 ans
et qu'à 70 ans tu dis merde j'ai pas de
retraite fallait y penser avant
il ya des gens qui vont au boulot en
métier raison on n'a pas le choix c'est
pour bouffer et m'assurer que j'y
reviens c'est une passion elle crève de
mélanie maintenir le retrait c'est ce
que je veux dire ça c'est la réforme des
retraites c'est faux vous alors moi je
ne connais pas la forme se comprendre la
réforme passion et raison mais compte
deux choses différentes
mon métier passion je respecte c'est
bien c'est de la passion ah oui mais
après il faut pas me dire quoi c'est dur
c'est dur les gens il aimerait bien
venir ici autour de la table se faire
maquiller prendre de l'argent
bernard mittal un choc on n'a pas
entendu là-dessus non énormément
d'argent je suis assez
je suis assez choqué par et mon jeu
extrêmement méprisant mais présente et
ça c'est choquant brave type mais là ils
extraient d'amour de dire est
intolérable inacceptable a alors allez
vite des intermittents du spectacle dont
ils sont capables les zombies sa vie et
vis-à-vis dès mardi a annoncé le temps
c'est l'étudiant habitants du spectacle
attend essaye pas dans mes un mec qui
vient ici dans les émissions à 8 heures
du matin qu'ils reparlent murs du matin
l'emmène pas avec toi lui parlez pas des
intermittents les intermittents il
travaille non ils font les confessions
parfois juillet août quand vous prenez
deux 2 mois de vacances ou en en hiver
la douce mené vannes oc n'y avait pas
tant ils sont passés non et le saint
père me semble plus vraiment à la drh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu es tu les achats reinartz étonnant et
mépris aujourd'hui je sais pas faire ces
jeunes maîtresses l'axone d'un camion
mais c'est juste pour dire oui c'est
juste pour dire j'ai glané personnes et
cette grève allait légitime et le droit
de grève est constitutionnel
voilà on n'a pas dix ans et moins alors
cette map assez belle manière sur les
comédiens je ne je trouve ça un tolérer
l'intolérable
est-ce que c'est effectivement par des
seuls les intermittents et c'est
internet
un intermittent comédiens un
intermittent comme une maquilleuse
l'internât décorateur normal comme kate
allen bernero même connerie monumentale
monumentale à la deuxième chose
le régime des retraites pour les
comédiens et pour les intermittents
c'est une catastrophe
salut j'ai un peu mal au nord je dis pas
ça un verre intermittence ont versé des
pressions indues catastrophe absolue
parce que effectivement d'une carrière
de comédien ou même deux cadreurs ou
dans le cinéma quand tu es maquillera tu
peux bosser beaucoup au début après plus
jamais ça sale habitude donc tu fermes
ta tu termines ou danseuse à la raison
tu termines avec 800 700 euros c'est
intolérable donc effectivement que les
ont connus se mobilisent pour cette
course est très fort voilà c'est très
bien et on peut pas dire que son nez
avec des nantis c'est pas vrai ils ont
pagnol dans le cul cul dans birth qui
est mon cas pour le veinard chine à
l'étude en moi j'ai vu mon père mais ou
pas on joue chacun renvoie de chômage a
pas pouvoir m'en mené nulle part de pas
voir beauf et c'est donc arrête de
penser que soi et soi même dans média
point par fut sans réponse à l'étude sur
la même scène marché vécu pendant
quarante années sans réellement je suis
c'est une passion que
laissez moi laissez moi laissez moi
parler pas vraiment tu ne peux pas les
mêmes non nous méditions là on respecte
ce qui a fait de la merde on respecte si
ce qui vous fait des comédiens ces
hommes on doit être les autres sur les
autres et ont semblé jean michel mr et
puis c'est un sujet de société c'est pas
parce que t'es pas directement concerné
oui est ce que t'as pas un travail qui
est pénible aux termes de la loi que tu
peux pas te d'exprimer sa contraire il
débat 80 sur la peine de mort t'as pas
besoin d'avoir quelqu'un c'est le
parcours tandis que j'ai pour la 2d
contre il a deja tu parles aussi pour
tes enfants c'est pas dit qu'ils ont
donné raison la question
c'est moins que ce qu'ils font un
travail mécanique de 7 à 6 la question
c'est est-ce que les people vient on
dénonce ihringen je veux faire plaisir à
tous oui faisons tous bref on s'en fout
des gens qui m quatre heures pour aller
au boulot après une demi-heure s'est
désolé